emotional connection between you and
these guys very emotional connection
between me and these cats extreme that's
his deal right now I mean this whole
deal is about just wanting petted and
loved on you know it's just they're so
affectionate are they trying to meet the
Netflix show Tiger King brought plenty
of attention it was still growing
problem people trying to turn giant wild
animals into pets lions tigers bears and
more still being bred sold and abused
across the globe for the last four
decades perhaps no one has done more to
help the problem than Pat Craig
you want to carry the chicken I'll carry
the chickens sure
at the wild animal sanctuary 45 miles
outside Denver
it's the Tigers who were Kings what do
you think you want this
and just up and over you know you do
oh yeah nice catch they're regular
Bounty consists of whole chickens and 20
pound Burgers oh yeah get it
so you've got four full-time drivers
whose only job is to run to Walmart to
pick up food right for the animals makes
me have five full-time drivers that go
to almost 100 Walmarts twice a week how
much food are we talking about we're
talking a hundred thousand pounds a week
of food that comes in here for the
animals if they eat a large chicken
breast like it's a peanut yeah
along with two other locations this
sprawling
789 acre preserve represents the life's
work of Pat Craig how many animals now
we're close to 700 right now
it's a lot yeah 700 lions tigers bears
wolves leopards so it's mostly large
carnivores how big do you want to get
well it's not about wanting to if it was
up to us we'd like to kind of be out of
business in the sense that the problem
was solved
yeah come on Craig got started when he
was just 19. after visiting a zoo and
being shown animals set to be put down
he decided he would try to find a home
for them on his family farm and sent 300
letters to various zoos he was soon
inundated with requests
from that beginning Craig's sanctuaries
have grown over a combined 10 000 Acres
protecting 20 different species
funded entirely by private donations
[Music]
they're really going
yeah that's that's not even Full
Throttle when they really go it's
that's him just kind of you can see he's
over there you know him standing up for
it yet he's he's taking it half serious
but when they're serious they stand up
they'll turn
and it's really cool when it's somewhat
cold out because you see the breath
coming out as you're born it's really
cool to see that
do you have a favorite animal
yes and no it's kind of like your own
children you know they're they all have
their different personalities lions are
are very family based they love to be
together they're very gregariously but
then tigers are very affectionate and in
a different way but it's more like
individuals and each one is very
endearing for their own reasons many of
the Tigers we saw Craig and his team
took in after the abuses they endured
were featured on the infamous Netflix
docudrama my name's Joe Exotic the only
difference between my pet and your pet
is mine have three inch teeth the Tiger
King brought so much attention to the
issue of animals being mistreated right
has that helped your cause it has you
know in the beginning everybody was so
shocked by it that we all kind of
thought well maybe this is going to be a
bad thing
um my goal is always to reach more
people and obviously those shows in the
timing of them with covid and all that
there was 70 million people saw it in
the first few weeks that it was out and
so for me it was 70 million people that
probably didn't even know the problem
existed when you saw the show what was
your reaction
well I when we rescue animals that's the
people we see all the time here in
Colorado Craig tries to do things the
right way he can never create conditions
exactly like the wild but it's close oh
you're backing off yeah
you know who's boss
not really
that includes an aversion to tourists
you have visitors here but reluctantly
yeah um I think that most people don't
understand that all animals it doesn't
matter if it's turtle or a dog or a lion
or tiger or Territorial and even people
are territorial
and so when people go to a zoo in the
morning before they get there the
animals are very calm but when they come
in everybody coming in is a stranger and
that's a threat to them and their
territory and so I knew that for us if
we ever opened to the public I had to
solve that problem I didn't want the
animals to have that pressure
and so that was when we came up with the
idea for the elevated walkway because
animals like this don't think of sky or
air as territory this is the longest
elevated walkway in the world the
longest elevated walkway or Footbridge
in the world and most people who come
here make the whole walk yeah it's three
miles round trip you know and that's
pretty pretty good for a lot of people
that haven't done a hike in quite a
while
the first time we tried to interview
Craig he got called away last minute to
rescue Tigers coming in from Guam
his teams also recently completed
rescues in Romania and Ukraine
he still tries to save them all we still
turn down quite a few animals every year
is it tough for you to do that oh that's
the hardest part is saying no you know
because
we're always working very hard to expand
and do more for the animals but there's
definitely animals I have to say no to
if you weren't here
would these animals be dead or
euthanized every one of them yeah we're
like the last resort for all these
animals we want to make sure that
nobody's going to get euthanized or
killed or whatever and and if there's
another opportunity then they should go
there because we have more than we can
take already and so we want to just take
the ones that are down to their last day
on Earth
it's an amazing Place wow and the fact
that people can go there immediately be
careful I well the elevated walkway is
careful but um and see what he's doing
the education I think is why he opened
it up to people so they can understand
what's happening interesting choice of
words he said so nobody will have to die
I mean nobody like and the fact that you
know I didn't who knew that animals
don't see sky or something above them as
being territory that was just a
brilliant
um Epiphany what a generous generous
heart yeah he has to do what he's doing
it's his life it's all consuming and it
hurts him when he can't save
an animal